we do indeed we have a jeffrey shawn a
man that is heading towards the playoff
jeffrey first of all two games against
one of the leading players in numerix
dress how did you approach this match
um i wouldn't say it was
anything
extraordinary by me in the first game
you know i tried to be as solid as
possible starting with black
and i definitely felt like he had good
chances
and i'd say i was quite fortunate to
to hold the draw there but
yeah and then coming into today as well
i think both of us had a very similar
approach which was
um if you know if we had a game then it
would be
you know a fight but if not i mean going
into the playoff was uh a reasonable
result for for us i think
he said that he felt some pressure
during today's game did you feel like
you're gaining an edge towards
the end
i i think yeah i understood what he was
talking about i guess you know with his
king in the middle
and i had some some pressure
on various
weak points but uh in general i think i
know this position uh from analyzing on
the black side and
it's usually
uh it can liquidate like how uh how it
happened in many different ways
so i wouldn't say it was
too problematic at any moment
i was about to say i think
you got to this rather key moment where
you did play the move d4d5 and just as
you were saying everything gets
liquidated jeffrey and you you get
a drug agreed uh
rook d one was the other choice and this
is where fabi said that his intention
was to try to play the move knight e7
and sacrifice the b-pawn if you take
immediately i can imagine that that's
something you really didn't want to do
but did you look at all
in in this uh line of play with with
taking on c4
right yeah i think this is the first
line i checked but i was also worried
about yeah so let's say bishop c4 here
bishop takes c4 exactly and
you're just
looking at this and you're just thinking
that white
should not be going down these uh
uh variations right i was thinking if he
i thought he could get the pawn back
like rook c7 and if he does just get the
pawn back then he has an outside pass
pawn and
also i think he gets the d5 blockade
so something of this nature is what puts
you off that uh
he he could sink and
sink a piece on d5 and his
passer
might be
offset your own
right it's your judgment yeah unless
unless i have some
wonderful tactic with d5 yourself or
something yeah yeah i
couldn't quite make it work i don't
think all right well uh how do you match
up how do you feel you will match up in
the uh rapids
yeah i think uh with
as fabi said we haven't played too many
times although i think he has gone the
best of me um at least the games that i
remember
so yeah i i think it'll be interesting
in any case um and
i think the format in general is is
really great for not only specters but
the players are also i think on their
toes here with all the different time
controls and
yeah i think it should be really fun
all right well thank you jeffrey good
luck in the playoffs get your prep man
that's gonna be an exciting one we